[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the time is finally here welcome to the
multiplayer reveal for call of duty
vanguard i'm greg reisdorf the
multiplayer creative director at
sledgehammer games at reveal we saw the
rise of special forces team and now
we've had our first technical test of
vanguard out in the wild the champion
hill alpha
our team is hyper focused on key data
points coming out of that test and thank
you for all the valuable feedback
today we will show you our vision of the
multiplayer experience for call of duty
vanguard on our last project we brought
the brotherhood of world war ii soldiers
to life in a more traditional approach
which was a great experience for
vanguard we're taking liberties and
risks to deliver something completely
fresh new and fun but first let's watch
the world premiere of call of duty
vanguard multiplayer
[Music]
warriors
saboteurs
assassins
their lives turned upside down by the
reich
each one with an axe to grind and when
we turn them loose
you better believe
they're coming out swinging
[Music]
[Applause]
on your rear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't see the
[Applause]
i'm enemy the place
my destiny
accessible
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta digital pre-orders get
instant access to the night raid
mastercraft and black ops cold war and
war zone
such amazing work that the team's been
able to do and we're thrilled to have
that trailer out in the wild our
multiplayer team is putting players in
the shoes of a globally diverse cast
we focused on special forces operators
that are untraditional gritty
anti-heroes from every front of the war
we've also focused on our down the
barrel experience to bring you brute
force weaponry that devastates your
enemies and world around you
today i have the pleasure of sitting
down with some of my colleagues i
haven't seen in over a year and some
folks that i've never met before in real
life
our conversations today will be broken
down into four different sections we're
gonna talk about our day one offering
for multiplayer we're gonna go in depth
in the gameplay we're gonna talk to our
art directors about vanguard's unique
look and take on world war ii we're
going to talk to our narrative team
about how they brought our operators to
life and we have some special guests
from bnox and raven plus following the
stream we've invited some of your
favorite creators to play call of duty
vanguard multiplayer so stick around
we're just getting started
well let's talk about some multiplayer
sounds good so we have 20 total maps in
the game we do 16 of them that are
working with core and they're across all
locations in the their western front
eastern front north africa as well as
the pacific and then the four maps that
comprise champion hill which is airstrip
market courtyard and train yard i do
love how we have found this fresh
approach to world war ii we really
really wanted this time to focus on a
global warfare and variety of settings
and when you think about the player
experience too let's say you finish a
match on gabutu and you just came from
the pacific theater and then the next
map that loads up is desert siege and
now you're in north africa so you're
just hopping all over the globe
so we just finished up alpha that was
the first technical test of vanguard and
starting today
you can pre-load for the beta which has
champion hill that everybody can now
experience as well as four new maps yeah
that's what i'm super excited about it's
core mp for the first time so it's red
star hotel royale gaboutu
eagle's nest i cannot wait to see all of
those players in there
and then we also have combat pacing
so you can now experience this huge
range from tactical combat all the way
up to blitz combat across those modes
that are in the beta
it's such a different experience between
when you're playing with blitz
and tactical as well because when you're
playing blitz it's just no holds bar
you're going
tactical is a lower player count so
we're actually increasing the time to
engagement in there and every shot
matters
you're able to play with it in the
filter system so within quick match play
you're able to be like oh i prefer
tactical i'm gonna be doing blitz i
remember when we were just first talking
about the idea of making every map into
shipment i love
that but having a map the size of red
star feel like shipment if you're having
that level of combat pacing is is what's
really fun because it's different map by
map it's so much fun to just go in and
you're not even worried when you're
getting killed because you just get
killed and respawn and kill someone else
constantly it's amazing
we also have patrol coming in as well
it's a new mode for vanguard it's really
fun i'm really excited to see how fans
respond i cannot wait i cannot wait it's
essentially the moving hard point that's
moving around the map on this track
you're going and you're taking it and as
people play it more and more and
discover new strategies around it like
there's play the patrol point hold it
down for your team but that patrol point
is moving no matter how many people from
your team are on it so if you're truly
you know playing as a team you're gonna
have people behind the patrol point in
front of it really locking down those
lanes that mode is bringing so much more
than we've ever had and you're also
exploring the entire map
playing with other players in these maps
being able to go into
you know clans they're coming into the
game they're a tier one feature you can
pair up with your buddies and your
friends we really want to lean into
social play because it does make all of
your experiences and those maps and
modes just so much better think about
what you just said about patrol too like
if you played patrol with your clan how
much more effective you would be if
everybody was coordinated taking the
patrol point at the same time yeah and
you actually progress with your clan
like that's a new thing that we have in
the game is pretty exciting and awesome
like
being able to have the three of us in a
clan and go and and be on progression
and you can be in a clan together across
jan as well that's right so we have a
huge commitment to our players around
cross gin cross platform play where you
can go and team up with really anybody
who has the game it's exciting for me
because now i can finally play with my
cousin in toronto who's a pc player and
i'm going to play on my ps4 at home i
really loved it as well because we've
invested quite a lot in our social
features it really widens the scope of
the social experience if you have a
friend who's playing call of duty you
don't have to now ask them oh what are
you playing on right you can just be
like join my clan we're so excited to
have call of duty vanguard launch the
team
has done a phenomenal job i can't thank
them enough for all of the effort
they've put in the most content day one
it's gonna be great
let's go
we're here to talk about gameplay so
this is reactive environments movement
footsteps create a class weapons
it's all about creating a fun
environment for the players to run
around in when we were thinking about it
as a team that that feeling of pulling
the trigger has to be awesome
and you need to be able to use it then
for gameplay as well it's all about that
player creativity when you first shoot
something and it reacts to it now you
start becoming a little more creative
about what you want to do with that
tactical sprint is in the game we have
it coming back and you can just sprint
through those walls as well
we try to give multiple options for how
you want to do things which really
allows for a lot of freedom
that's right when you're taking cover
behind something
they can also flush you out you start
seeing this stuff just start getting
shredded you can mount on top of these
surfaces as well
i love sliding into cover and either
mounting on the side mounting on the top
blind firing over the top so blind fire
like let's just talk about that for a
second because blind fire is all new
addition to vanguard it's kind of the
hip fire of mount
we actually have it set up where you can
ads and go into mount so when you're
near something you're going to go into
mount every time you do that but if
you're in cover behind it your gun's
going to come up and now you're actually
in this state where you you know you can
blind fire over you get a little peek
over the piece of cover that you're on
and you're now able to move back and
forth across that fire
you get the hip fire spread
and then once you see somebody coming
you can actually go right back in the
mount and transition between the two
and it's it's so fluid it just feels
like it was always supposed to be there
destructible environments are throughout
the game it's on every map and it just
changes the map over time that's right
like the the state that the map starts
at is going to look different than the
state that it ends at
everything really changes especially in
different game modes when you have dom
and hardpoint
and even with this idea of combat pacing
around those structures like we have
tactical combat facing where now
destruction just matters so much more
when there's a lower player count and
it's so much more intimate and then you
go into something like blitz which is
just crazy amounts of players in there
and those maps completely change based
on how that combat pacing is flowing
throughout every playlist that you're
going into and those modes even
we have a caliber system as well which
interacts with these destructive
environments and so you're able to now
go caliber up or caliber down within
each weapon the heavier the caliber the
more it's going to
change the the look of the walls
it's not just visual either increasing
the caliber does increase the damage the
bullet does so we're kind of moving away
from this concept of protecting rate of
fire and damage we're letting the
players control it
we have create a class in the game and
we're building on what was done in
modern warfare 2019. you got your
primary weapon
secondary weapon three perks lethals and
tacticals it's about choices and about
the player having choices within create
a class there's so much going on in
there we have the gunsmith system coming
back we have caliber system ammo types
10 attachments as well that you can put
on the gun
the coolest thing about 10 attachments
is that we were able to make it so that
some of the attachments are much
stronger than the other attachments so
you have a lot more options kind of
taking
our 30-ish guns and bringing it all the
way up to over a hundred because you can
tailor them to whatever you want them to
be
and it's still familiar with the perks
the three perk slots and you can
actually modify those and get some
modifications around some of the other
core gameplay pieces and with these
weapons and with this caliber system
there's so much in there to be able to
use we have certain perks that are
dedicated to it yeah you might choose an
lmg and then try to combine perks for
close range to make it so much more like
an smg but with that power and the ammo
size that the lmgs are bringing or you
might go the completely other way
lean into our new mounted movement
system so you can slide around the cover
you might equip it with piercing vision
as one of your perks your perk too that
allows you to actually highlight people
through walls that you've suppressed
suppression is a new mechanic that slows
people down
and with that like that is going to give
us the most tactical experience you've
ever had in call of duty yeah we're
trying a lot of risky things allowing
players to tune things like damage and
rate of fire but we're committed to
figuring out the right values there
making a balanced game
we
really want to push the envelope and we
really want to bring players a version
of call of duty a flavor of it that they
haven't tried before it is truly the
most immersive call of duty experience
i've ever played and we're in this
together we're in it with the community
we're there getting feedback from them
on all of these elements and it and we
want to make it the best for everyone
on this project i feel like the
collaboration between creative direction
design and art there's a lot more
cohesion and so we've grown together in
such a way where we can have these great
conversations it's about stepping out of
our comfort zone exactly
on the last project we took on the
brotherhood of the soldiers it was a
very traditional look at it this game in
vanguard it's a fresh look we wanted
something fresh and we wanted to get
into that anti-hero
this time around we we kind of dug
deeper and we tried to understand what
the soldiers were going through and it
changes the way that they walk it
changes the way that they talk even the
way they would dress and how they would
stand it had to be somebody that was
real and
somebody that we felt that like i want
to be that person
i want to play that person i kind of see
myself in that person i think that that
was big too right like so who's your
favorite character when i saw daniel
yatsu i thought to myself hey you know
what i want to be that character because
that character kind of feels like me you
know and i think that's huge
i just love that our game we're taking a
character-centric approach you actually
have a roster yeah you get to learn more
about them yeah it makes me want to play
every character and they all have
different looks as well that have their
personalities in them the character team
has done a lot of great work
to recreate you know all the materials
and things like that i mean they dress
the mannequin as the exact character
they scan it there and then they
virtualize the authentic gearing
the same thing happens within the maps
as well
and so we even have some maps that are
actual spaces in the world
we typically start with a block mesh of
a map and try to figure out how we can
get photogrammetry assets to match that
block mesh we tried it the other way
around on this one and that would really
capture the spatial relationships of the
buildings and the road and the hedges
you know it feels like a real place it
also helps with the tone because when
something feels more realistic you take
it more seriously you know and when you
want to be immersed
you don't want to be pulled out by
something that feels artificial
and there's so many other things that
we've done to this engine like we've
done a lot with foliage that's in our
pacific maps just speaking of simple
things like foliage the way that the
light hits the leaves and then like
bleeds and then shines through makes it
feel more realistic we've been using
some new software techniques to
generate simulations for really windy
situations where the palm trees are
colliding with each other and it really
makes the map have this energy to it all
of those atmospherics like the battle of
berlin cavuto like these maps have so
much weather going on and it's been
exceptional to see it in the game
neo epic lenses is something we're
looking at game wide we want to add that
new fresh badass on top of the epic
setting
and that's something that you developed
yeah with the art team
we talked about what's the thing that's
going to set us apart from the previous
game that we made together
and so we talked a lot about the
contemporary lens
and that's where the whole neo aspect
comes
neo noir it's a new evolved version of
film noir movies so epic is its own type
of movie
we wanted to take cues from the great
epics of the past and add a neo rebirth
to it a lot of that has to do with
composition of the landscape
the types of environments that we pick
to play in the palette the color a lot
of it has to do with the tone
the art team has done an amazing job
just the entire team as a whole has done
an amazing job making this look great
with all the content that we had to do
we needed the rendering we needed
engineering we needed the effects the
lighting the whole team we needed studio
and melbourne to get it looking super
awesome in a way that we can deliver the
the best cod game we can do
we have a cast of characters those
characters also come over into
multiplayer we took the personalities
from our campaign
and brought them to the wild exaggerated
crazy world of mp
flight revenge we have 12 operators that
launch six in the beta all from
different walks of life
what is bringing those characters
together in campaign captain butcher
who's a returning character from call of
duty world war ii he's back he's got a
much larger role now we needed a
character when we went to the special
forces the connective tissue who like
was the guy who went around and found
all these people to give birth to this
new type of warfare and he puts them
together and he sends them into these
incredibly dangerous situations
sometimes you need a job done that's
when you call the professionals
so these special operation task forces
that we have the sotfs what are these
that's the whole notion of multiplayer
is that this is butcher forming these
teams you know they do feel like ragtag
people pulled from all over the world to
form these awesome squads of elite
soldiers
so when you unlock one of these
operators you get that moment to learn
more about their backstory
melinda do you have a favorite one of
those i do my favorite is for solange
who is dutch aruban
and she
was plucked from her everyday life and
put into the war and she did strategy
and i think what's interesting is with
our characters we also not only touch on
people who fought on the front lines
we touch on people that fought at home
or were taken and not primed for war
they were just normal people that wanted
to live normal lives and then the war
happened and everything changed
you can't change your past but you can
choose how it molds you
most of the time in in multiplayer
you're selecting the character you're in
the game you're in the action running
around we have a couple that are just
like absolutely crazy don't we i think
paulina's really sinister actually and
you get more of a
look into her character
it almost makes you like afraid of her
it's about immersion about putting
players in there and these stories are
just fantastic
[Music]
we wanted to champion a lot of
the forgotten stories of the war and a
lot of them are female-led stories there
are a lot of women that had a part in
the war whether on the home fronts or on
the battlefield
[Music]
we created so much lore around them and
their backstory and who they were as
people and also we wanted them to feel
like distinct pieces on their own as
you're you're randomly assigned an
operator when you when you start the
game you can now use that operator as
much as you want and then they have
operator progression which is a brand
new thing where as you're leveling that
operator you're getting cosmetic rewards
they have charms that are based on their
backstory new cool animations that we
use in the game for finishing moves and
everything else that really immerse you
in that experience
we don't have factions in multiplayer
it's team a versus team b it is a very
deliberate decision but it's one that we
found
was for the best of the game it allows
players to
be able to customize their character and
how they want to play you know once we
made that call it was really important
to then really dig deep into find all
those different characters because it
was a global war and people were
fighting their own battles in their own
countries
i do think though there's a lot of
opportunities for people to learn about
new perspectives and new angles on
things that happen during that time
period so a lot of diversity in our
characters not just in their race but in
their appearance their gender and all
those explored more in mp they're all
fictional characters grounded in world
war ii but they are based on real people
and real groups that did fight in the
war another thing with campaign is the
character you're playing as we don't
want them to talk too much to sort of
allow the player to live the fantasy so
in multiplayer we get to actually make
them talk and you can hear them talk
more didn't think i'd come back
that brings me back to life
you had that coming it's multiplayer
it's still a game but there's so much
history there there's so much depth and
richness
and you've been able to bring all of
this together into the story that is
quite amazing
[Music]
hey everyone my name is mark alexander
the ui ux director at binax and today
i'm here representing binox the lead pc
developer for call of duty and we are
very excited to bring you call of duty
vanguard pnax has put together a
dedicated and passionate team to push
the quality of the pc version each and
every year
we want the game to be tailored for pc
community by supporting both the latest
hardware technology and also optimizing
for the best performance
with call of duty vanguard you will get
the greatest features and improvement
that we have built over the years such
as bandcap framerate the ultra wide and
the multi-monitor support and also a lot
of settings to fully customize your
experience throughout the game
and about customization we wanted our
game to be even more accessible we added
option to reduce motion thickness
improved text readability and we even
added adaptive ease of use settings to
fit your gameplay's time
we've also done a ton of work to improve
input latency by using a high speed
camera combined with an arduino board
and an nvidia ldat it's a device that
measures input to photon latency we're
able to identify opportunities to
improve reaction time in terms of
milliseconds we have also reworked or
autodetect features as you may know you
optimize all the graphics settings based
on your hardware but this time you get
to choose if you prefer to have the
awesome visual experience or aim for the
highest frame rates
lastly while waiting for your friends to
jump into your party or during a round
transition we added a setting that
reduces the brightness of your other
monitors to allow multitasking without
missing any of the action
we have so much more to talk about in
the upcoming months and we can't wait
for you to experience call of duty
vanguard on battle.net now i'll pass it
to raven to give you the latest intel on
what's coming to warzone this year
i'm amos hodge associate creative
director at raven software
with the launch of vanguard we want to
ensure that the feel and character of
the game extends beyond the multiplayer
experience and into call of duty warzone
i am pleased to announce that there is a
brand new warzone map coming this year
shortly after the launch of vanguard and
we are going to
the pacific featuring an entirely new
play space complete with all new points
of interest players will get to traverse
the lush landscapes of the island and
make their way through a variety of
extremely cool locations while battling
it out alongside friends and foes our
goal was to create a fresh new
experience for call of duty players
by breaking out of the war-torn world of
her dance to create an atmosphere that
is vibrant alive that is really opens
the doors to how we can craft the
narratives and events
as far as visuals and technology warzone
pacific will share the same tech and
engine as call of duty vanguard this
allows for seamless weapon integration
and play balance fully optimized cross
play cross progression and cross-gen
support will be enabled so you can play
with your friends across different
platforms and generations of consoles
but most importantly we want to ensure
that warzone pacific will be the best
experience it can be we will be
launching with a multi-faceted new
anti-cheat system that will be rolled
out with the new experience goes live
later this year we're putting it through
the final paces and testing and are
excited to have it ready day one when
the new warzone experience releases our
teams have worked hard on this and much
more and will continue to do so we know
how much it means to everyone we will be
continuing to offer a massive calendar
of free post-launch content featuring
new modes playlists
limited time events and seasonal events
as well as community celebrations and
much more
we look forward to playing with all of
you later this year when the pacific
officially comes online
[Music]
we sincerely appreciate you watching but
there's so much more for our fans to
experience from the beta through launch
the beta will be running over the next
two weekends and you can pre-load on
playstation starting today for your
first look at live gameplay from call of
duty vanguard core multiplayer tune in
now to one of your favorite creators
from the entire development team around
the world thank you so much for joining
us today we can't wait to see you in the
game
[Music]
get it on
[Music]
[Music]
you